whoo
it's gonna be good
season three take one
[Music]
my name is george moats and i'm about to
make your hit the microphone sorry
don't touch the microphone my name is
george most and i'm about to make your
burger dreams
come true normally i think you're used
to seeing me with a thin patty
burger in my hand not today today we're
going in a different direction today
we're going to the thick
steakhouse style burger you can identify
a steakhouse burger
by its lack of adornments we're talking
about a burger that is nothing more than
a great piece of meat very thick copious
juices inside
and nothing more than maybe some onion
maybe some cheese
and a pretty simple straightforward
sturdy bun that's it
so you're probably thinking you know
george you spend so much time eating in
these great
dives what makes you want to sit down at
a fancy restaurant eat a burger this
burger will
probably set you back in any restaurant
well over 35 to 40 dollars
but let me tell you something people say
it's too expensive for a burger
in this condition in this case it is
absolutely 100 percent worth it
take the upgrade people eat the goddamn
burger spend the money look at that
look at that steak i'm going to mash up
two of my
all-time favorites in new york city
mineta tavern
and red hook tavern we're gonna make the
perfect
steakhouse style burger right here by
using
caramelized onions american cheese and a
funky dry aged patty
let's do this i'm hungry i'm starving
actually this smells amazing
oh [ __ ]
the meat the star of the show of course
and think about when you're making a
burger that only has
a few elements each one of those
elements have to be perfect
this meat is not just any meat this is a
beautiful two inch thick dry aged ribeye
that comes from
a friend of mine's meat packing facility
in new jersey
bigger meets have you ever walked into a
driving room
it's amazing you ready for a little
field trip
this is where dry aged beet comes from
so what is dry aging dry aging is the
process of leaving meat open
in a controlled environment allowing the
meat's natural enzymes to break down
over time and create tender beef dry
aging also allows for environmental
impact
as well for example moles in the room
can find their way
onto the beef and flavor the beef molds
like penicillium
algiovense penicillium brook forte for
example
brook fortress sound familiar right it's
the same thing that makes rockford
cheese
funky dry aged cuts are not for
everybody but i'm telling you right now
for this burger it makes it awesome
funky yeah
what is this a 45 50 piece of steak
right here
what you could do though is blend it
with some economical cuts like
chuck for example i'm gonna put them
together we're gonna do a 50 50 blend
grinding cutting i'm also not a butcher
so be patient me
i'm just a hamburger guy if i cut myself
well wouldn't that make good tv
look at the marbling on that piece of
steak so i'm doing i'm just i'm just
trying to slice up pieces look at that
oh my god hello that's gorgeous
so i'm basically going to grind this
into a bowl
some chuck to the bowl so it's kind of
mixing up naturally
a little chuck that's gonna be funky and
fatty and
luxurious ah
that's gonna be good let's make a burger
i use something called a food ring
this thing right here how much meat do
you want how big do you want your burger
to be
i mean six ounces that's probably six
ounces
and we're just gonna press it into the
mold somewhat gently
make sure it's all filled out in there
and i use the mold because it makes nice
uh
edges look at that oh look at that thing
so i'm actually gonna cook it in a pan
this is the first pant oh [ __ ]
the hot and it's hot this is the first
pan i ever bought
i was a bachelor living in new york city
that's the first thing i bought i think
i bought it for literally a dollar at a
dollar store pastor george was fun i sat
around and read books all the time
that's how i became so smart i'm just
kidding i didn't do that
so you just sit around and talk and
think you know everything wait that's
kind of like me now hang on a second
here we go i did that because i want to
make sure it makes
perfect contact with that surface more
salt on top
i have this at about 450 degrees right
now here we go
i'm gonna flip it
at mineta they take beautiful
caramelized
onions and put it on top right
these are these are caramelized is that
nothing more than thin sliced onion
red wine some butter and some beef broth
and everything is reduced
this could take this took two hours to
make on top of that
monetta will add butter i stood by
and watched the chef make a burger for
me at manetta
and they used i counted 11 spoonfuls of
butter
can you smell that oh no you can't
because you're not in my house
i'm sorry wow this is incredible
i'm now going to put cheese on top now
most of the fine establishments that
make these burgers
don't use one slice but two
[Music]
two slices of american cheese that's my
ode
to bread hook tavern the caramelized
onions and the basting of the butter
that's my ode to mineta it's a perfect
mashup
oh yeah
oh [ __ ] oh it's just my belly
not a big deal oh my god
but yes burning it oh look at that
perfectly toasted bun look at that
perfect oh yeah
[Laughter]
oh my goodness you see that thing
look at that thing you see that you see
that
ah did you see that
i don't know what the [ __ ] that was that
was intense
holy [ __ ] are we okay here
i'm waiting because i don't want to burn
my face off you want me to burn my face
off don't you
[Music]
oh
oh my god
oh wow what
you look hungry
oh
wow i've made a mess over here of myself
but it's so good it's worth every bit of
it
wow it's good right once you're losing
listening up on a bun this is the burger
that
actually drives home the point that a
hamburger
should taste like beef that's it right
there
everything else on here supports that
the caramelized onions
the butter all these things are part of
the flavor profile
that makes you say wow this is why i eat
burgers in the first place
this thing right here see you next time
when we go somewhere else and we eat
something
outside
see you next time when you watch me have
even greater respect
for burgers it doesn't end i like
burgers a lot
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where